jonathan majors from the hit lovecraft
country show good
country show country chat the cmas are
here people
most likely i think it's official now is
playing king the conqueror
ant-man 3 mcu debut villain we're gonna
watch a short
video from cosmic wonder for a while we
thought it might have been modoc
kang is not too far off i suppose
let's check it out
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel cosmic wonder
where we talk about all things marvel
and
everything relating to the mcu and today
we have some huge
mcu news as king the conqueror is
seemingly heading to the mcu and we
apparently have an actor that has
already been cast to play him
kang and ant-man 3 is something that we
have expected for some time now
we knew the film was in pre-production
and as it turns out they're a lot
further along
than we thought and ant-man 3 is going
to be a much
bigger movie than anybody anticipated so
let's break down everything that you
need to know for starters
small but bigger big he can blow up
too according to deadline jonathan
majors has been cast for a role in
ant-man 3 and they believe that that
role is kang the conqueror
if you haven't heard of jonathan majors
you've probably seen him at one point in
time and you might have seen him on
lovecraft country
and according to deadline this is our
kang now king the conqueror appearing in
ant-man 3 was a pretty popular theory
due to
the quantum realm of course in avengers
in game the avengers used the quantum
realm as a means of
time travel and king is the master of
time travel
and in the comics king has quite a
complicated story but he pretty much
battles
every single avenger and not just every
avenger but pretty much every hero as
well from thor to spider-man
now you never really know what marvel is
going to do with one of their comic
characters but it definitely seems like
marvel is going to stick true to kang's
time travel and that is why they're
putting him in ant-man three
now in ant-man and the wasp so excited
for that man secret city
in the quantum realm that's happy for
anyone
told us to look out for this they're the
ones who showed this to us
and they're the ones who told us that it
was a big importance in the future
now everybody thought that it was going
to be an avengers end game i
totally missed that now discovering that
jonathan majors is most likely cast as
king of the conqueror
it does look pretty simple does that has
something to do with kane
and this is what they're going to
explore in ant-man 3. wow
possible that the fantastic four could
show up in ant-man 3 as well
we've gotten some recent reports today
it's a little much but
all right bigger film than it's ever
been before
and they're going to involve a lot oh so
happy for a man
people thought it could just be the
young avengers but now hearing that kang
is most likely coming it would make
sense that the fantastic four would come
as well
we'll do a full breakdown soon of
everything that you can expect from
batman 3 but in the meantime let me know
what you think about this news that
we're probably getting
kang the conqueror in ant-man 3. let me
know what you think in the comments down
below and i wish you was playing mode
[Laughter]
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
wow that's crazy
yeah i mean if you got kang in there
fantastic four
ben affleck's batman michael keaton's
batman
oh my god and then they restart the
whole mcu timeline verse
never know what you're gonna get see my
big question is when are we gonna get
kodos for all you simpsons
fans
i know what you were doing you were lis
you were waiting for me to do my joke
and then you're like i don't want to
enter i'm gonna
i gotta i got my joke my john joke i
wanna throw in here
instead of working off a craig's joke
i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna wait i saw it i said to
see i could see your reflection in this
part of the camera right here
going where are we going again
well i feel like an idiot you don't have
to man
i do the exact same thing to you all the
time i
see you doing everything i'm like he's
waiting for me to finish this
fight start talking against the weekend
yeah i do
i do it all the time that's the reason i
know you were doing it in the comics
king is nathaniel richards who's related
to
reid and franklin richards and richard
jenkins wouldn't you know it
yeah that's a great one sorry not even
that's just his first name not even his
surname isn't that crazy
yeah man that's how it works he just
flipped it around like they do in
asian countries i wouldn't really want
the fantastic four to
appear in this movie specifically i
think
automatically having kang and if he is
nathaniel
richards if they're doing that version
of him yeah
then automatically that's a tie-in of
fantastic four and i kind of feel like
that's all we really need
especially because this is ant-man three
you're already going to be introducing
kang
by having kang in there you're opening
up a whole new can of worms
holding you quanto can you got something
no do it do it do it dude you can do it
okay
words i thought it would be better no
can with the jeans like oh we
[Laughter]
richard this is the richards consortium
i kind of feel like that's enough i'm
excited for
ant-man the franchise specifically
because it seems to be that
one franchise within the mcu that just
has
a difficult time really getting through
the cracks
like an ant i'm trying to find as many
ant puns and none of them have been
panning out this whole video
yeah you know it really it has a lot of
weight to carry and one would argue that
some of that weight is often a lot
bigger than the mass of its own
body but that's what ants are good at
man is carrying
wow immense weight uh above their head
that's it
john's taking over the channel um yeah
yeah here we go we finally made up for
that
audition no but um
that's what i've come to love about
ant-man though is like it started out as
and even after ant-man 2 people were
talking about like oh is this
gonna fizzle out as a franchise it's not
like one of the big
home run hitters for marvel but at the
same time i have really come
to anticipate ant-man and really endear
and become very endeared towards the
franchise because it is
sort of the off to the left one where
yeah you might meet a new villain who
sounds very
imposing but what i flash back to is
that the previous ant-man movies kind of
got
a little creative with how they
approached these stakes and their
antagonist
characters and stuff like that and so to
have a character like kang
figure in also time travel obviously
going to be a part of it
like that gets me yeah excited for not
only just being back in the ant-man
world but seeing what kinds of other
crazy quantum
you know size things they can do i mean
to your point
that is why i love the ant-man franchise
like it's standalone films in and of
themselves i just think
that in terms of box office reception
and i know i've touched on this before
but in terms of box office it's never
been one of marvel's you know
big juggernauts i kind of feel like that
often has to do with
when they're releasing ant-man however i
think when you're introducing a villain
like king the conqueror and with the way
how they'll be
amping him up especially as a very
integral
important villain for the next phase of
the mcu
his connection to the fantastic four i
think that could draw in a much bigger
box office number ant-man movies they've
made a lot of money
but for some reason when you like hear
about the reports from box office or
when hollywood websites
because it's not the you know the
chugger or not yeah it's something
that the other mcu movies are oh is this
flopping is the ant-man movies gonna end
oh it becomes a speculation even though
i'm like no they've made a lot of money
they're just not making the money the
other mcu movies are making
and i feel like by having this kind of
villain in the movie
that could draw a lot more people into
wanting to watch ant-man in the movie
theaters
or video on demand depending on how
things are going excites me for the
franchise to get that extra boost and
that much extra
attention drawn their way and i feel
like getting a villain like king the
conqueror
a time traveling villain which if this
image that they were showing from the
quantum realm it looked like it was from
the actual ant-man movie
i missed out on all the reports or all
the speculation that was talking about a
city be within the quantum realm and
marvel specifically saying to look out
for it i did i did i missed all that but
if that seed has already been planted i
think that's
way cooler having king the conqueror
being here after having your end game
movie which dealt with time travel
then to have a villain come in who might
be
upset about the way the time travel
world has been i don't really know what
his motives would be
i imagine peyton reed and the people at
the mcu would want to do their own
little take on him they'll make him
really funny
yeah he's just here he's just here to
pick apart the time travel mechanics of
endgame he's like you guys came in and
you read
facetime now i gotta fix it and he's not
even how did captain america get all
those stones back
yeah none of this makes sense i don't
even want to fight i just want to argue
with you
i feel two ways about the fantastic four
element because while i'm not excited to
have an overly bloated film that needs
to introduce reed richards in the entire
fantastic four because they might also
have young avengers
in here today yeah exactly i do think
that it
because there's such a natural
connective tissue and because ant-man
movies of all the marvel movies have
something broaching more on whimsy kind
of like the fantastic four
can i feel like it would be an
appropriate place to at least like flint
spark the fantastic four
even if you don't actually feature them
in any sort of heavy way but to like
promise that they'll arrive you know
soon after in
ant-man 3 or something would be cool
because a villain like kang
is avengers level villain not not just
an ant honestly it's a part of me that's
a little bit surprised by
him being the one major but that's i
mean they could be using this as a way
to really elevate ant-man
and the thing with a lot of these solo
movies is a good amount of the villains
are kind of a one-off
or they get killed in that particular
installment come back later as like a
bit part for the timeline
oh he's there i'm very curious to see
what they do he doesn't seem like the
kind of villain that would be a one-off
i don't know maybe i'll do some like
type of
portal scene at the end he's trapped in
some other time dimensions or whatever
alternate timeline i could see them
ending it with that as opposed to
killing off king the conqueror in this
film but we'll see
either way i'm excited to see what they
got in store and uh
i'm excited for the ant-man franchise
this is cool news i'm excited for
jonathan majors
wonderful wonderful actor i mean the
only thing i've seen him in his
lovecraft country i'm not that familiar
with his uh
he stretches the kind of actor who i
might have seen in other properties and
i'm like oh
i didn't realize that he's like a
starring role
yeah he's great on that show like he
really is what do you guys think about
this news what do you hope they do with
king the conqueror here subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell thank you cosmic wonder for putting
this video together last but not least
i wanted a shout out today katie ann i
just wanted to let you know all i
want to let you know is that i really
appreciate
the hell out of you you have been
absolutely
100 supportive kind
honest very caring creative
when you didn't need to be creative for
us yeah generous
i hope that we can stay friends until
john is dead then i cut ties with you at
his funeral
i this is what i wanted i i asked for
this in my will
katie anne specifically is in there i'm
like we will all
remain close until the day i die and
then no more
i don't want to think about what you
guys could be talking about while i'm
gone and
i want no association with anyone that
had any ties to john after he's dead so
give while you can
except for jones hot mom
what's going on mrs humphrey
my mom alone katie don't come near my
mom all right sorry katie
actually started off really great and
then it just went sideways you know how
we do
no in all sincerity thank you yeah
seriously all i want to say
is thank you for being you and i 100
support you
[Music]
you